did you look at your goals every day
this year every day did you look at your
goals every day this year it's such a
simple question every day i don't mean
once in a while every day if you didn't
my invitation to you is to consider the
fact that maybe the amount of time that
you're spending with your goals is not
sufficient enough to motivate you maybe
the amount of time you're spending with
your goals is not sufficient enough to
keep you focused maybe the amount of
time you're spending with your goals is
not sufficient enough to activate that
unconscious brain that says huh i know
how to achieve that maybe it's reason
you're not coming up with more ideas in
the shower in the morning because you're
not cueing your brain with enough
repetition of looking at your specific
goals because when you look at your
specific goals over and over and over
and over again day after day after day
after day it literally helps rewire your
brain and it helps program your brain to
say oh let me pay attention to ideas
thoughts and feelings i have consciously
and unconsciously that might be able to
manifest these goals this is why having
a visual representation of what you are
after and looking at it every day is so
critical to all of personal development
training of all time but why is it that
so many people still do it they just get
caught up more people look at other
people's instagram every day than they
do their own goals and we wonder why so
many people are struggling to achieve
things faster need motivation watch the
top 10 of believe nation because i love
it hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you are
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best brendan
burchard and my take on his top 10 rules
for success
enjoy
rule number two
cultivate when we lack motivation it is
a slippery slope to suffering
so please
recognize that you must cultivate more
motivation
what else can you do
well i'll tell you it's like ambition
attention to those ambitions effort
towards those things i think all of that
is is really really really clear but i
also really believe that a lot of
emotion motivation
is simply lost
because of fatigue
so let's say you're doing all those
things but you're wiped out you're tired
like a lot of motivation really rests on
how you feel physically if you feel
lethargic you feel tired you have the
flu
it's like it's harder to be more
motivated you can still do it by doing
what i've talked about re-cue yourself
reconnect with those things but
health-wise
it's really critical for you to say okay
if i want to be motivated long term i
need to feel greater levels of mobility
and energy in my body so if you ever
hung out around me i'm constantly
bouncing and moving and breathing if
you've been with me at hpa you see some
of these practices this breath work that
i do that i'm activating and opening up
my body so that my body says let's go
versus
right so my body's not like oh i ate
this terrible thing instead my body says
i feel refueled i feel ready to go let's
go rule number three focus on passion
drawing activities
focus on doing activities that draw your
passion
don't focus on the success the outcome
the final goal the final destination
a lot of our discouragement comes
because we're trying to make that
specific thing happen and we have a way
in which we think it has to happen
and let me tell you what i know a lot of
people who they actually did that
they they work diligently for years and
years and years to manifest their dream
and now they've you know they've
achieved the outward appearance of that
success they've got the bigger house the
bigger cars they've got the you know the
yachts the boats the fancy vacations you
know abundance in every single way and
they're unhappy
because along the way
they were focusing on those external
things
versus the activities that bring them
joy
passion and fulfillment
and what happens is you want to
compromise
on the activities that are actually part
of the dream
so that you can have the dream right
it's that person who works a job that
sucks for 20 years to finally get paid
something to finally quit that job to do
the thing they really wanted to do so
for 20 years they did things that they
weren't even passionate about
fooling themselves like well i just need
to save and save and save and finally
one day be able to go do my dream and it
doesn't really like make any sense
don't give up 20 30 years of your life
doing something hoping to earn the right
to do the thing you want to do start
doing the activities you enjoy and make
you feel
challenged or creative or satisfied or
fulfilled or on fire now
i think that's what's so important
everyone thinks the dream lives in a
destination
and i always say no no the dream lives
in the activities that you do today
are you doing today
what you would do if you had the
outcomes you seek because i know a lot
of wealthy people who are miserable in
their lives they achieved outward
experience but they're miserable because
they're not doing the activities in the
day that actually bring them joy and
fulfillment
so if you need patience throughout this
journey the patience will come from
connecting with the activity every day
like don't wait to have the dream
do the dream
and if every day you touch that
like experience do you do you you're
doing that dream every day even just a
little piece of it then you don't get so
discouraged you know when you get
discouraged when you're just not doing
it
but there's almost no dream that you
could have that you can't be doing
something
and touching that every single day some
activity every single day that is
actually part of the dream
you know i have a friend whose dream was
to become a world-class chef
and so they were going you know they
were like saving all this money to go to
culinary school and they were having
like terrible jobs and they were just
like i'm going to be a chef one day i'm
going to be chef one day i'll be chef
one day and i hung out with this person
long enough to go hey man i know your
dream is to become a chef but you don't
even cook
right now
and like no no i'm working to save to go
to culinary school so one day i can be a
chef i'm like no no you can be a chef
right now cook dinner tonight in an
artistic fun way touch the dream now
rule number four look for collaboration
we look for people who have a passion to
take initiative add new value we look
for people who have a spirit of
collaboration you know what the spirit
of collaboration always ends up being
it's two things number one
spirit of collaboration is enthusiasm
do they have enthusiasm for the job for
the gig for what they're doing does that
enthusiasm show through
like i always hire for enthusiasm but
then two collaboration requires openness
it requires openness to new ideas to new
people
and that openness when people have
openness they have a different way of
receiving and giving feedback
they're more in the learning mode
and so we're looking for that
my friend evan carmichael's book listen
humans are built to serve some people
are built to serve the world
others want to serve the 25 people
closest to them but in either case
humans are built to serve so if you're
not happy right now it's because you're
not serving enough you got to pick up
this book because it's so inspiring to
remind you that we're all here to
contribute to make a difference to make
an impact and this is your field guide
for that rule number five know what
you're looking for you need a 30 45
minute interview tops
like interviews should be quick because
you should know what you're asking for
by the time they get in the door you're
either you your hr company or the
staffing company you're working with
they should have already done the
preliminary work to see like when they
come in the door they're already
qualified like at a technical level or
an interest level like they should
already or project management level or
or you know
you see their library of work before
like it should be obvious that they
could do the job or they have interest
in the job so by the time they get in
the room
you're not really qualifying their
intelligence or their skill sets or
their personalities because frankly you
could assess all that before they get in
by looking at their resume by looking at
their library of work in the past uh by
giving personality assessments in
advance if you want to do that kind of
thing some of our companies we give
personality assessment in advance some
of them are we don't
so it's up to you
so
you have to imagine by the time they get
in the room
the whole point by the time they're in
the room is that's a few questions
to really gauge them on the things that
are most important to you rule number
six prioritize health so i manage my
sleep my diet my health
in ways that support my mental clarity
and energy
and i know that
like sounds sometimes people think
motivation is just a mental game i'm
like yes but your mind and your body are
connected if your body is lethargic so
is your mind right that brain body
connection is real y'all and i know you
know that you've been sick you've been
tired there's times when you've been out
of shape you feel terrible so i'm here
to encourage you as i always do if every
single month in high performance i have
to cheer you on to get in better health
to prioritize your health to sleep good
to eat well to move if i have to do that
every single month i will do that i will
be a champion i will cheer you on i want
you in excellent health this year so
please hear me cheer that on every
single month because i just know i get
you in better health
i get you in better mental health
we get you in better mental health it's
easier to sustain that fire and that
drive rule number seven master necessary
skills
patience is easier when you are
constantly learning
mastery and what i mean by this if
you've heard me teach a lot i'm often
telling people make sure you know the
five critical skills
that you would need to develop to become
world class at whatever you want to do
i mean to become really good at what
skills would you have to master
like for me i would have to master not
just writing but i would have to master
how to promote a book how to build my
brand how to run a business
uh how to communicate on video and
stages i had no idea how to do like any
of that and you can tell i still suck at
some of that right it's like it's not
easy but because on the way to become
best-selling author
i was always studying how to do all that
stuff
learning
can make you feel more patient because
you're like learning is giving you
progress learning is readying yourself
for that moment you get the big break
learning makes patients easier because
your mind feels more competent it's like
you know what i'm learning here
at least i'm getting some momentum maybe
you know the doors aren't opening maybe
the bank account isn't filling up
but my mind is getting sharper at this
i'm developing skill
and when you develop skill your mind
says hey progress we're doing okay when
the mind says hey progress we're doing
okay patience is so much easier it's
when you're sitting there you know the
people used to say trolling your thumbs
now they just say playing video games
it's like when you're sitting there
playing video games all day detached
from the dream not doing activities the
dream and you're not learning
you really fall into complete detachment
from progress and now you just
it's not even a matter of patience you
just flat out give up
because the mind
needs a sense of growth and that growth
has either come from learning or doing
rule number eight hire for the heart set
questions like what attracted to you
what attracted you to wanting to work
with us
like what what about our company or this
role made you passionate about it tell
me about a time that you set a difficult
goal and you hit it
tell me about a time that you were on a
project or had a goal and it totally
failed how did you handle that that gets
to the points i made earlier who do you
admire the most
and why
i love that question because you'll
start to see people's heart come out
in an interview who do you admire why do
you admire them but also who do you want
to be a hero to or who do you want to
admire you
which is a really great question because
it gets people really thinking about
how they live their life and for whom
and it gets to a more personal level
often in interviews
what do you think
would make you successful here
that kind of checks have they paid
attention to the company do they know
what they're applying to do they know
what your culture is like they have any
have they done their homework let's see
have you seen our website or what we do
in the marketplace do you have any
advice that we could already be better
like where where could we improve what
we do what do you know about us what
could we do better give us some advice
to see if they're actually paying
attention what project would you
consider
your most significant career
accomplishment i just like to say what
what's a project you've done that you're
really proud of that was really the most
important thing
and you hear and get to see their
passion and their enthusiasm and the
sense of fulfillment that they might
have we also like to say why would you
like to be part of this team
like what is it about this place these
types of questions
they're not the end-all be-all questions
you could go pick up any you know book
on interviewing at your local bookstore
and see and yes please go to your local
bookstore um and see like hundreds and
hundreds of questions you have to know
what are the questions important to you
and that's it
that's it and if you ask the right
questions and you get the right vibe
then it's like okay because by the time
they come in the door they can probably
the job
now in the interview it's all about
those things of can you see the passion
feel the heart feel the fulfillment see
that they're a good person see they have
enthusiasm about it see that they're
ready and they're hungry to do the work
see that they're confident we did you
know we've done interviews in the past
with some of our companies the persons
we interviewed they lacked like they
didn't really want to be there or they
didn't seem like
they would be good fit for a team they
were more of like the individual
contributor they were smart but you
couldn't see that they would be like
willing to work with people and you're
not trying to hire all the same type of
person but you or same type of skill set
but you are
as a leader and you should write this
down you you're not trying to
hire the same person
not trying to say hire the same iq
or personality
but you are trying to hire the same kind
of heart
you're trying to hire somebody who has
enthusiasm for their day for their work
the kind of heart that wants to do
excellent work
the kind of heart that wants to get to
work the kind of heart that cares about
other people
so i was saying when you're building a
culture you're not building a culture
based on skill set you're building a
culture based on heart set
like are these people who care enough
about each other and have high
enthusiasm in their life and for the
role
and if you get that right you're going
to create some kind of magic and people
won't know the magic they won't know you
thought through all this but all of a
sudden they'll start seeing it right
right off the bat they're like oh
there's something special going on here
and it's because you hired for the heart
set not just the skill set rule number
nine be intentional intention intention
intention
for me i train myself on the three words
i want to be and i'll remind myself just
remind myself those three words remind
myself those three words remind myself
those three words because it's easy for
me to reactive and be responsive instead
i would be intentional
so i know those three words that really
defined you and repeat those like
oftentimes around if you ever see me
around like this
all i'm doing is i'm kind of rocking i'm
breathing in and out deeply i'm getting
attentive to my body and my posture and
i'm repeating my three words just to
reconnect because i do that every day
in the moment of crisis because see
moments of crisis it feels like
everything's out of control but what can
i control
breath
body awareness what i say to myself
breath
body and errors what i say to myself i
do that over and over and over again and
it really helps me lock back in
i hope this supports some of you because
emotionally
learning to be centered emotionally will
so support you
as you go to change your life and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is reflect unfun
times
what is fun for you
right i know that's so basic but can you
really think of i mean if i ask you
right now and be honest if i ask you
what are the top you know 10 most fun
times you've had in your life
do they come easily to you
see for most people it doesn't they're
like well that was that time that i went
on a roller coaster and i jumped out of
a plane or you know that time i was at a
wedding and i danced like a chicken you
know
like they really struggle and partially
what happens for people is they just go
through life kind of bumbling and
crashing around and they never have any
real reflection
on what brought them joy happiness
engagement enthusiasm fun
so what i do is when i have a fun moment
that and then i i'm a big journaler as
many of you know i i'm always
encouraging you at the end of your day
journal about things that you're
grateful for things that you desire
cool things or um inspiring things you
saw people say or do
you know just journal about your life
about philosophy whatever it is but i
like to write at night and i always try
to write also a component of what was
fun today
i reflect on what was fun so for me you
know i've got so many access points so
many references of what was fun in my
life it's just immediate that i know the
things that bring me great joy because
i've thought about them
so do you have your fun list things that
bring you great joy and great fun in
your life and you know what those should
be
your to-do list
because here's what people do their
to-do lists every day are tasks
not life
and that's why they're miserable they've
gotten lost into the minutia of what
must happen versus who they could be
that day and that's where their life
starts to derail and they lose that
charge it's so magical in life so what's
your fun list you know what are those
things that you could do that would
bring great joy and fun into your life
and do them more often and automatically
you're having more fun
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the question
of the day i want to know what was your
single biggest takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week when you just watch a video and you
get motivated the sign says you have a
35 chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action but when you
watch a video you get motivated and you
create a specific plan of action that
number jumps from 35 percent to 91
chance of you following through and when
you publicly commit to other people like
leaving a comment down in this video
your number jumps to 95 chains of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself so i want to know
your single biggest takeaway from this
video and your plan of action for the
next week leave it down in the comments
below so i can celebrate you
you don't have and have not developed
friendships
with other people who you talk to enough
who are doing the activities of the
dream
and trust me i know that like as a
writer i mean you guys see me on youtube
and instagram and like doing videos all
the time with our challenges and our
courses and our podcast oh my god
but
i'm more introverted than you think i
would be
like i can go out and and just crush it
to an arena of 30 000 people all day
long no problem but then i need to go
back and just like not talk to a human
for a while i have a big introverted
like part of my life and as a writer
i would write by myself all the time
and i wouldn't collaborate with anyone i
didn't have any friends who were writers
and so i was always impatient i'm like
is this book ever going to happen
am i ever going to get published am i
ever going to have a best seller and i
was losing patience
because i didn't have community
when you have community like literally
friends who you can call and go you know
what today sucked i didn't get anything
done i didn't create or hey you know
what
i'm just not feeling anymore i wonder if
i should quit
but they're on the path with you they're
like hey no don't quit hey listen to
that dream that was sewn in your heart
follow that work for that earn that like
having positive friends
who are on the same journey
is one of the most critical things that
people fail to set up
because when people running people say
well brennan but i just don't have any
friends so i guess i'm gonna fail like
then go make friends leave your house
people like but i don't know anyone
doing this i'm like go volunteer for an
organization that's doing something
related to your dream oh i don't i don't
know anybody in my local community who's
not a jerk i'm like go volunteer because
guess who volunteers good people giving
people people who want to make a
difference people willing to give their
time money effort towards good causes
get around them and as you're around
them start asking do you know anyone who
does
this thing
i just started getting around everybody
in volunteer organizations when i was
coming up in my 20s and i would say hey
do you know anyone who's like a writer
who like you know writes articles or
blogs or books and they're like good at
it
and these people i was volunteering with
like oh yeah i know this person oh talk
to this person i'd get an introduction
i'd ask them to go out to lunch and i'm
like and i would just ask them
questions and then we became friends the
next thing i know we're going to lunches
we're going to the bar we're hanging out
and now i'm in that world when you are
in the world of your dream
it's here
you're touching it daily because of your
social
relationships so make sure you develop
friends who are doing what you want to
do it will carry you through those dark
days
when otherwise you'd strive by yourself
the first thing you have to do in order
to improve your mind is take total
control of your attention and notice
where are your thoughts right now
at a very continual basis you have to
think where are my thoughts right now
are they supporting me or are they
automatically coming up negative and
self-protective in ways that are not
advancing my life just to be aware to be
conscious of what's going on in your
body in your sense of feeling and
emotion and the sense of the thoughts
you're actually having just start paying
attention you know for a lot of people
because they've never done this before
and it's hard to remind them to do it
it's like simple here's what i want you
to do just start paying attention to
your thoughts
anytime you're in line
any time you're in line from now on if
you're in line at starbucks just say i'm
in line at starbucks brandon said think
about my thoughts what are my thoughts
saying right now just checking in you're
in line in traffic waiting for the next
car to sit and think what are my
thoughts right now and just notice what
you've been thinking about the more we
notice what we've been thinking about
the more we can interrupt
what we've been thinking about see if we
just allow that feeling to keep coming
up and you don't pay attention to it our
life can be very frazzled and very
highly anxious but once we say what's my
mind on right now and we redirect it
that is where personal power comes from
first awareness right and understanding
and the consciousness to what's going on
but then the ability now to be
self-directed to choose what we want to
focus on so first we're attentive to it
and then redirect it if it's negative
it's not supporting you redirect it how
do you redirect it first and foremost
you just say what would be the opposite
of this negative thing then you think
about the positive thing and you focus
on that and you repeat it to yourself
for many people that might include
closing their eyes just visualizing a
more positive outcome thinking about the
more positive outcome thinking about the
more positive outcome thinking about the
more positive outcomes focusing on with
their eyes closed and that visualization
of a more positive outcome of how things
could turn out well or how good the
situation could be better or even just
what are the next steps i should take
visualizing that
and assigning a high amount of
importance and duration to it meaning
making that thing important to us by
making it how do you make something
important you give it a sensation
you feel that thing you sense it you
sense what your next step would be you
sense i would feel it the outcome would
be better how would it feel emotionally
psychologically spiritually for that
thing to allow it to have a lot of
emotion to it pay attention to your eyes
close you see that thing you feel it you
sense a different step you know what
you're going to do you pay attention to
it and you keep focusing on that just
over a period of minutes keep focusing
and keep focusing focusing when your
mind automatically wants to go back to
easy which might be negative
you go no no no i don't want to i don't
want i'm not into easy right now i'm
into conditioning my mind
focus focus focus focus give attention
duration and sensation to it attention
duration sensation attention duration
sensation visualization visualization
it's repetition of that positive
alternative to a negative impulse that
comes up that gives us personal power
let me say it again it's that attention
to that positive alternative
over attention to repeating that
negative impulse or thought that gives
us personal power you know so many
people say to me well brendan i'm wiped
out i'm tired i i wish i had your energy
or whatever i know a lot of people don't
want to have my energy it's too annoying
i get it
but what if we had you tap back into
your aliveness again you know what if
you just chose not for any reason not
for what emotions come up in your human
body because emotions just come up right
your nervous system sometimes you don't
even know why you feel what you feel
like something can be trigger you a
sound a movement something someone says
or just your physical body of what you
ate a couple hours ago or how much you
slept three days ago can catch up to you
and your body and your emotions can kind
of go
but we have the saying the power plant
doesn't have energy
it generates energy
what if your dominant frame
said you know i'm going to focus on my
aliveness and you started cultivating an
aliveness in your body and in your mind
for no other reason than i said so no
other reason that you decided to said
you know what today i'm going to focus
on what's great about me but i'm also
going to focus on being fully alive and
engaged and present how do you do that
just what if you just felt more grateful
for the life that you had
you know look you're breathing you're
you're you're alive you we we have this
incredible gift that we're all here
right now you know it's like i'm here
you're here what if we took that
seriously and we started realizing what
a gift it is to be alive and we allowed
ourselves to feel alive not for any
reason no one made us happy no one did
anything for us we just felt alive again
and we started asking ourselves on a
daily basis what level of aliveness do i
feel in my body right now do i feel at a
level zero like dead
or do i feel like a level 10 i'm fully
alive fully engaged fully present and we
willed ourself into feeling more alive
every day it's the number one question i
get from all of my work is like wow you
have a lot of energy on what you do how
do you get it i don't get it i don't
find it i generate it the power plant
doesn't have energy it generates it if
you want to feel better about your life
generate more aliveness for no other
reason than you choose to life should be
incredibly
valuable to you if you really value your
days like this day becomes valuable so
because your day is valuable you get
stuff done you know why a lot of people
end up feeling really broke is because
they're not valuing their day they're
broke because they added no value to
their day they were reading celebrity
gossip magazines they were screwing
around online they were doing nothing
that actually moved the needle in terms
of their personal progress and their
professional progress so value this day
you want to make more money get serious
about tomorrow
value that day ask how you can add more
value into the day really work the day
and as you do that over and over and
over again you ask how can i serve how
can i contribute how can i take it to
the next level you do that long enough
the breakthrough happens the magic
happens and the money
takes care of itself most people don't
have a calendar
so that's problem number one
they're not strategically blocking time
moving towards
the major things they want in their life
they won't say they're going through the
motions but the calendar reveals it like
if i parachute in their life and i open
up their calendar and there's nothing
there they can't possibly say they're
living with purpose or intention and
that sounds so flippant to say but i
can't believe how many people
they're not planning their skill set
development they're not planning
specific goal attainment on certain
dates so just like their calendar is
completely empty and they're hoping it's
going to happen and it's like you look
at mine it's like it's like
military-esque like planning big biases
i had
that were wrong
and you're not gonna like this one and
no one's going to like it but creativity
is not strongly correlated with high
performance
i would have three years ago i would
argue i mean i would have been i would
have passionately argued against because
i'm a creative yeah this is my life i
write i train i speak that's what i i
would have argued forever i've designed
all the covers of my books yeah i mean i
dork out about design i design all my
web pages i'm i believe that creativity
must give the edge and it does give an
edge in some
certain circumstances for sure
but
i interviewed a fortune 50 cto chief
technology officer
unbelievably high performing people
their stocks off the roof and but what
he said we go is brendan i'm not a
creative person my team isn't
particularly creative but long-term
success matters just as much about
execution and consistency and showing up
as the creative edge the creative edge
might get you in the game because
remember high performance is long-term
success we're not studying initial
success it's very initial success you
know grit creativity originality all
these things very important the spark
the get you in the game for sure but
even jim rohn said you know motivation
gets you in the game habits keep you
there
and creativity uh as a habit that the
spark that might be called
original creativity it might only happen
for us every two to three years so
that's not sufficient we got to show up
on monday and tuesday and wednesday
execution is more important as an
example so we talk about the kinds of
creativity that actually matter
but it's not strongly correlated almost
across all industries and i would have
completely argued with that last night
i'm going on the stage right if i if my
identity says i am a public speaker
and it is important for me to be
excellent at this
and then i go on stage and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology in the field of psychology
saying do not tie your efforts to your
identity because that risk of
disappointment or rejection you know if
the task fails
you shouldn't take that as as a defining
moment in which you say i am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped out on its face and
go well actually um
no i do get bothered
if it fails i really get upset about it
i am attached to
the process here i i do care if it turns
out well i mean that's why they obsess
about the details that's why they care
about excellence it's like no one
obsesses about the details or cares
about excellence unless it means
something to them
and there is a risk the risk is
you over attach
to
the process of the outcome
with your identity so that if the
processor outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human
and now you stop
your progress
but i also tell people
there's a balance there
i actually wish more people would attach
some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much i mean i
think what the world needs
less of is half interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what
i'm gonna be an excellent parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they i want them to own the
identity of a ceo because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even
hobbyists it's like if you want to win
your identity has to be tied into that
thing in which you are trying to succeed
at and give to and that takes a lot of
guts to put yourself all in for
something but who's ever contributed
something with tremendous impact without
being all into it i've never seen it so
i think the message of the book you're
right i'll get some flack of
a lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity or my friends who are buddhists
will say but attachment is the form of
all suffering brandon have you not read
your spiritual attacks i'm like look out
calm down i've hung out with the dalai
lama i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you is even
the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader his identity is still
there that people
you know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having any
attachment to something but i'm like i
think
we all want to be present and engaged
fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i
am all in this the habit is generate
energy
okay not necessarily have energy create
energy create energy and what they do
the way we measure that was kind of
academic
mental energy which is tied to your
focus and your stamina and your ability
to manage complex tasks without too much
mental stress
number two is emotional energy
which is just the quality of your
positive emotions
and number three is physical energy
high performers are 40 percent more
likely to work out five times per week
than
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15
most high performing people in the world
tend to work out five days per week
and that workout could be defined as you
know 45 minute brisk walk or you know
hit intensity or whatever it is but
forty percent more likely that's a huge
finding
and what we found is high performers
just have
better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
um one stunning finding was uh
ceos senior executives and business
owners
they report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now i
can imagine yeah yeah i kind of i was
surprised by that i would thought you
know athletes would be ten percent more
i mean the emotional and mental energy
yeah after the decision making the
conversations the big deals the
stakeness
yeah it's a lot of energy it's a lot
that's why
i mean if you really want to achieve
your dreams you have to care for your
body yeah your mind it's why all these
things you know finally resonating in
the marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break
or you know
managing your own energy sleep is
everything yeah um and i think all of
that is really important and we say
generate energy because there's this
myth that
you know some people have happiness or
they have it's like
no you generate you don't have happiness
you generally create it yeah you create
it and so
the quality of your energy you have to
create like you and i both i mean if
most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days was like how is lewis even
able to focus right now and how are you
able to get here and do this as well
yeah but it's because we say well this
is our mission
show up man yeah you know there's plenty
of times i gotta imagine you walked on
the field and you were like
i'm spam exhausted you know i remember
when you like flew down to compete
yeah i still play with the usa team
handball yeah team and a year ago i i
flew down to
i remember i did an interview in miami
and then flew out from miami and then
went and just went right into training
camp and then played against brazil
which is like you know olympic
olympic qualifiers and yeah got our
assets booked but it was fun you know
but i had to have clarity yeah she
didn't show up even when i was like oh
we're gonna lose yeah like there's deer
a chance yeah it was like the worst team
in the nba playing like the warriors and
we were just like we had no chance yeah
but i had to show up and give my best
and you have to set all these routine i
mean you know the the amount of routines
that tom brady has in his life so that
he can generate energy it's unbelievable
stuns most people it's unbelievable and
that's just that that's that's what it
takes if you want to be at that level if
you don't want to be at that level you
don't have to do it yeah you don't have
to do it i mean everybody can just like
well i'm going to go you know hit the
cinnabon but it's like
it's pretty good how do you want to feel
at 3 o'clock if you want to feel amazing
at three o'clock don't end lunch with a
cinnabon you know you wrote that
achievement is not the problem alignment
is
can we talk about that a little bit yeah
uh i wish it was my line it was uh one
of my clients
she's uh
i mean she manages over 10 000 people
like she has 10 000 direct reports she's
she's just an unbelievable achiever and
when i started working with her
i mean
just like a lot of people their
struggles aren't
can i make a goal list and a checklist
and you know can i get things done
because people get stuff done all the
time but our busy work isn't always our
life's work and so you have to learn
that
we have to find that
thing
that we can align to
and a lot of people they're achieving
themselves into the wrong thing they put
the ladder against the wrong building
they
just haven't really figured out what's
important to them and most importantly
alignment also includes harmony in your
life
because a lot of people achieve
achieving their career and then they're
divorced achieve achievement achieve and
they're fat and they didn't take care of
themselves and and they know it and it
sounds horrible to say it but they know
it and so you have to figure out like
okay how can we align ourselves
something that we really care about and
not align like sometimes on a monday or
tuesday or not just in our career but
really get our relationships our health
our career all in alignment to help us
become a high performing because high
performing isn't just achievement for
achievement sick i also every morning
lay in bed
and
i visualize what i want
and i see like when i first when i wake
up i literally just lay there for an
extra two three four minutes and i just
kind of visualize and i'm thinking about
the things that i want so it happens
every morning
are you willing to share an example
actual example so from age of 20
to 26
uh probably 90 of the time i would lay
there and i would see myself
on stages big stages and i would sit
there and as soon as that image came up
i'd
freak out
like i'd imagine myself walking on stage
with an arena and i would literally just
start sweating in bed i'd lay there in
bed terrified like just
awfully uncomfortable because
that wasn't me
but i was like
everyone was saying your car accident
story brennan really
made a difference in my life
uh this whole idea of having reverence
for life and having you know the
intention of who you want to be all
these simple things that we talk about
personal development but i'd share my
story of people and think oh my gosh you
need to teach that and i was like oh i
started hearing that i said maybe i'll
learn to teach i learned to talk only be
more expressive because where i'm from i
grew up in an irish mining town
that had been economically depressed for
a century
like men didn't communicate
there was no emotional expression if
their hands came above their waist they
were punching through the face you know
i mean it was a very physical and very
violent place i grew up in but there
wasn't
emotional expression so i lay there and
i'd see myself like talking and moving
on stage if you visualize yourself on
stage what people are watching now are
listening now if you close your eyes and
you see yourself on stage public
speaking with no podium no notes to
10 000 people in arena
most people will get clam your hands and
start sweating if you really see it and
think about it and feel it and put
yourself there for two to three minutes
i did that for six years for three to
five minutes every morning
i'd hear myself saying something i'd see
myself moving i'd see the audience
clapping or jumping up at the end i'd
see myself moving across the stage in
ways i never moved and that
visualization
created that skill set
because then i'd go and i sometimes i'd
wake up and i was like oh i was good i'd
try it out
on the carpet you know i'd get up like
oh i like that i try it out and i try it
out just in my little dorm room
then my little apartment and i was
always trying things out and i always
wanted to get better at it and always
want to get better at it so it just
depends sometimes as a specific goal
like right now i'm also work on some you
know major media goals you have to be
all in and it's the hardest thing to do
because if it fails then you can feel
like a failure um you know
i think of this idea of performance
necessity um two stories kind of come to
mind one is i was working with an
olympic gold medalist sprinter
and we're in the tunnel and we're going
out and he's talking about the
competition and we get out to the blocks
and i said
uh he was really worried about the
competition i said well how do you even
gauge like who who who's gonna win
you know in in his particular race
people are winning but by you know 1
100th of a second tenths of a second i
mean these are really close sprints and
i said well how how do you know
i said who would you even bet on
and he says
you know i would
bet on the guy
who gets down at the blocks
gets himself settled looks at the finish
line then says
i gotta do this
for my mom
and i was like oh
that's good his performance necessity in
that is
it's necessary for him to win that race
for his mom
um i think of
you know when i started
my career and i really decided to go all
in
with writing and online training um this
is like 2000 probably six
i'd gone broke completely bankrupt and
failed i left my corporate job i had
this cushy kind of corporate job as a
consultant good job
left it to write
and i didn't know how to make it as a
writer i want to do seminars workshops
didn't know how to do that so i was
pretty much a hot mess ran out of money
um i got nothing to my name
nothing kind of no positive prospects no
one's calling me except the guys who
want the money
and um
one night i'm riding and the apartment
was so small on the bed i had
uh
you know what my bills my vision boards
all my research
all my journals like the bed was
basically the desk the extended desk
and my lady comes in denise and
she
walks past me but she sees i'm like
trying to write so she doesn't want to
disturb me she goes she crawls under
the covers of the bed
and i'm just typing kind of casually
typing away
and i look over
and
i see my woman
sleeping under my bills
and it was just like
you know
because none of us want to see our you
know
our family suffer because we are
not performing sure
and um
i was just like
i gotta figure this out
and i'm telling you i wrote more that
night than any night in my entire life
next day i wrote more than ever that
burst life scold and ticket became a
best seller and in you know 18 months
later because i was like i'm going to
figure out this online thing i'm going
throughout marketing i'm going to figure
out how to teach i'm going to how to
train and get paid for it because i've
never really been paid for those things
i said i'm going to figure out this
industry and i'm gonna make it 18 months
later after her
crawling under the bills i made 4.6
million dollars jesus online
total transformation people like how did
you do it i'm like she gave me she was
my necessity
i was not going to let my woman
be in that situation
and she believed in me she supported me
she she married me
and
you know but that was she was my drive
and the second part was i went all in
with my identity i said i am going to be
a great writer
and i am going to be one of the greatest
online trainers there ever was
you know as you said in the intro now
we've graduated over 2 million people
have taken our online courses video
series now
i don't think it would have happened if
i hadn't had the guts and maybe
the no other choice
to say this is who i'm going to be
and i'm going to build into that
and it's necessary for me to become that
person
so let's go one of the major major keys
we found the first high-performing habit
is seek clarity
and what we found is one of the
practices that high performers do
is they define the feeling they're after
and so when we had to explain that and
later talk about it in the energy
chapter we had to differentiate between
feelings and emotions and they are
different emotions tend to be they're
the same yeah like we have they're
physical they're almost always automatic
even though when the brain is creating
associations there's also happen for us
they just kind of emotion comes up yeah
you're watching a movie and you're just
sad and you're like oh my gosh you know
i'm crying you didn't even have the
tissues right you're just like
you know uh but the feelings are usually
interpretations that we make of
what that emotion was and how it sticks
and the meaning we give it to it yeah
and the example i used you know i like
to give and i don't remember if it's in
the book or not honestly because here's
what's happened this book is 400 pages
it was 1481 when i finished baby you
edited
and it was 1481 good complete like it
was like awesome yes but i was like
that's going to freak people out so
we're publishing a bunch in academic
journals later and just stripped it down
to 400 pages so it's more readable and
fun and orientable so i can't remember
if this one actually made it in there
but um the example i like to give is if
you and i go to a haunted house yeah
which i love i love them i love them and
they scare me the crap but if you and i
walk around you know you walk around
when the walls in a haunted house come
jumps out at you yeah you and i are both
going to jump yes we are emotionally
going to experience fright
immediately it's going to be there right
but i might be freaked out for the next
five minutes
and you might be laughing
why it's the meaning and the feeling
that we've defined it as
that's fine for everybody here's the
issue that people have and you have to
be careful about when we start talking
about energy because emotional energy is
real yes and that is
look if at six like we we go to the
haunted house at you know 5 p.m in the
afternoon
if at 9 00 pm now you're in your house
you're alone but you're completely safe
and you still feel
scared
that's not the haunted house's problem
that is the way that you are defining
and working through your own emotions
you had the emotion of terror and fear
and you're still
experiencing that feeling
that's a mental job
not an emotional job
so your job is to go wow
i'm at my house i i've lived here for 10
years i've never been threatened this
house this is a safe place
i gotta redefine the feeling i wanna
experience and i work with one uh an
olympic sprinter gold medalist olympic
sprinter as a client and
this person's huge breakthrough
in getting better and going from
literally uh one olympics before not
meddling at all to now gold i said what
made like what was the thing yeah and
one of the things they said to me was i
learned to define the feeling
and i said what do you mean by that and
he basically said you know if if
if there's a bunch of us at the starting
box and we're all in perfect poise in
perfect condition the one to bet on is
the one that says this is the way i want
to feel in this race right now i know my
emotions are going crazy like my heart's
beating i can hear everybody i'm waiting
for that shot blast i i can see my goal
i know how important this is and all
these um like their emotions are there
yeah
but that person is defining the feeling
i'm going to feel centered now i'm going
to get myself in the zone now
even though the anxiety is the emotion
of anxiety is there for all olympic
level
competitors all of them but they define
that feat that emotion as a feeling that
helps give them a performance edge
and i think that's important too you
know bruce springsteen says if he's ever
backstage and doesn't feel like
nerves he's going to hang it up yeah
but that's anxiety he's just defining it
differently so what's the first social
habit
uh increased productivity
it's kind of like no duh high performers
are productive dudes um but what
what the uniqueness is
they've
they're not just pushing more paper or
checking more boxes because you know i
both know a lot of people who you know
their busy work isn't their life's work
so they don't feel fulfilled for their
productivity high performers are
fulfilled from what they're
accomplishing which is a big big big
measure
and here's what they did they identified
their primary field of interest
which is a big deal
then they identified what we call pqo
prolific quality output which is what's
the outputs that matter and get
recognized and rewarded the most
in this primary field of interest
and then they went all in at it
they became almost singular focuses like
you know when when jobs came back to
apple and got rid of all the product
lines that these are what we're doing
that was prolific quality output we're
gonna be prolific quality output on
these things not those
so it's important like for me
i thought for there was a period of my
life
where i thought my primary field of
interest was personal development
and that's what most the world knows me
for i i've never
posted any marketing on my facebook page
in terms of like marketing advice uh i
teach that
that's way down in my funnel
my front my youtube my podcast
facebook are all just personal
development so i really identified with
that
and then i launched my first book life's
golden ticket
which was my life's message
and it kind of bombed
it had best seller and then it died you
know bam wow yeah
and uh really bummed me out
and i realized why i said you know what
i've been thinking my primary field of
interest is
personal development
and so i folk i did all the book i read
all the books i went to all the seminars
i you know studied with the gurus i
became friends with you know wayne dyer
and tony robbins the big names that's
what i thought it was
and then i had to make a shift and i
shift my primary field of interest
to
how to share a message
and it completely shift
when i started learning i was like you
know what my primary field of interest
needs to be is how to share a message
because i already got the message right
and then i said well what's prolific in
this area what's prolific is is what's
recognized in this particular area right
at that time with this 2006-7
online video was just coming in i mean
youtube and facebook were young youtube
was like 2004 i think yeah 2005 or
something young
and
but what's mattering now is video and i
went all in you know i've created 13
online courses
because in my primary field of interest
sharing that personal development
message was everything so i learned how
to share everything and i went from you
know kind of
a busted
uh
first book to an 18 months
4.6 million in revenue wow
because i learned how to sell and i
learned that sharing and selling a
message was just as important because if
you don't make the money you can't
sustain the message i had the message
but i wasn't making any money i was the
poor broke writer dude and i was like
so i shifted my primary field of
interest and i went i got to understand
marketing i got to understand business
and what's going to be prolific in those
in what i'm doing now
and that's creating products to sell
oh i got to create more products higher
quality products i showed you like my
brochures and yeah beautiful stuff just
like super branding you know all my
books uh you know i created i did all
the covers of all my books and i
obsessed about i was like the the look
and the feel and stuff i didn't care
about before
and
that changed everything so what i tell
people is if you want to increase don't
just get more stuff done get more of the
right stuff done
and really go in on it i mean super
obsessed about the quality
and really focus you know it's that old
saying the main thing
is keep
is to keep the main thing
the main thing exactly yeah
oh you got you very careful what your
main thing is the big huge finding that
really scratches the surface of a lot of
like cultural assumptions is especially
in high performance is this big cultural
conversation we have about strengths and
you know find your strengths follow your
strengths the strengths are everything
and you know take the strengths finder
figure out your top five strengths
follow those don't do anything else or
you know at least know what they are and
really aim your career to that or aim
your behavior towards that or you know
use that as a guide for recognizing
pattern and by the way i'm all for
that's all great i'm that guy who says
you know what any self-reflection you do
i'm cheering you on
like any assessment any tool that makes
you look at with inside i'm like all for
it it's just that
strengths are not highly correlated with
long-term success
right there's not a lot of data and
there is not a lot of research that has
shown it leads to long-term success with
the positive outcomes uh associated with
what we care about in psychology which
is we care about happiness we care about
health and we care about your positive
relationships
and this myth that oh we just follow our
strengths to you know
to the promised land
is just not true when you actually talk
with high performers
because my favorite question then if it
was down this just go up to anyone who's
good and say were you always good at
that
and then be like
no they're gonna be like not at all
well did you always have an inclination
to do every element of do where you're
doing really well no like me
man i sucked on stage this year i've
talked to 60 000 people live this is
really important because
this idea that we're just our strengths
are gonna give us everything it's just
it's just not true i sucked speaking on
stage uh matter of fact i was terrified
of it
terrified
but one reason i love your show
is because i had that intention of i
want to make an impact and when someone
actually asks
and and kind of owns that like when they
say do i want to make an impact and the
answer is yes and they own it
they realize they're going to have to
develop they can no longer leave their
growth to
meet you know to to to randomness
because if they do they'll always be
mediocre and they realize i got to
become something entirely above both of
those
that's what most people don't see
they're like
it's we made this binary
false conversation right it's a it's
it's not a true sort of choice here it's
a false dichotomy we call it right it's
not strengths or weaknesses many of you
if you have a big dream a huge goal you
got to become something entirely above
and beyond any strengths you even know
about feel or own and go way beyond any
weaknesses you've ever even addressed or
even you know about because you're going
to discover so many new strengths and so
many new weaknesses on the path that
it's almost irrelevant what they are now
it's what's the goal and build into that
you know i didn't know how to write
i get a lot of critics who are like
literary guys about my books because
every book is different
right six books all of them different
and the reason they all read differently
is i'm challenging myself as a writer
to develop
to get better every book i write i'm
gonna write this like nothing i've ever
written before
and i go to work at building a new skill
set
to be able to write like manifesto
i researched for two and a half years
just how to write it wow not what to
write
how how do i get that pentameter how do
i what was the rhythm in which
revolutionist rhetoric
was spoken in or written in just to
understand that took me two and a half
years so i had no conceptual
understanding of it it wasn't a strength
i didn't even it wasn't it wasn't on my
radar make small changes and see
themselves making those changes
and then integrate that into their
identity integration if you heard me
talk about it it's a big topic in high
performance it's it's one reason
successful people often don't feel like
successful people or successful people
don't feel confident because they've
never integrated the winds
the wins wins they've they've had a lot
of wins in their life but they never
stopped and said
wow
i really appreciate that i got a little
better today
i i really appreciate that putting
myself out there i'm proud of myself for
trying here um you know what i am a
little stronger because i did that thing
to acknowledge that you've gained some
strength
is everything to confidence isn't it
write it down to acknowledge that you
gain some strength
look if if you had two kids and you
survived
you've gained some strength
you get a little more confidence in life
i mean come on what else do you have to
be through if you've already made some
money in your business but it's always
more more and more more and you never
stop to go
wow i really came from nothing i made
some money here and you never integrated
the win in your identity your identity
stays the same level
over here
even though you've actually accomplished
a lot over here
and i see that all the time it's why i
see people who are the same level of
confidence in their 20s and 30s and now
they're 50 and 60 leading other people
but they're completely wracked with
insecurity every night they feel like
crap they don't know what they're doing
and i'm like oh my gosh you should have
so much more confidence you should feel
good about yourself integrate some of
these wins four day event
and it's just me
i usually have one or two big names come
in but it's me 12 hours a day four days
and i never sit down high energy i never
sit down on stage
and super high energy i mean really
going for it a lot of just the clapping
the jumping butt really just spending
heart you know how hard it is of course
and uh
i had to about the same time when i was
35 i had a a a famous strength and
conditioning coach backstage he works
with me in usher and
and he uh he's like what do you eat back
here and you know another guy came in
and strapped the heart rate monitoring
machine he goes
i'm equivalently burning
uh equally working out at the marathon
level
every day
for four days
they're like you're not eating i was
losing on average 11 pounds
every man i do eight events a year so i
was losing 88 pounds a year
you know it was like it's horrible for
your health so i had to learn how to eat
i had to learn i do ice baths every
night at my events which smart no one
loves to do that
here's the thing i used to do it every
day in football like during the season
yeah and we it sucks for the first month
but then you start to love it yes yeah i
have to do it you know what i mean it's
like you just start to ah i feel so good
so it feels so good after stage you know
it's last 12 hours so those are
no one says i want a habit of taking an
ice bath at the end of the day
but if i want to be high performing on
stage
that's the choice yeah now obviously
people listening you know consult your
doctor of course yeah um for 10 minutes
don't stand for half an hour yeah right
right so but all those things you have
to so what are your habits for energy
and the funny thing is you sit down with
high performers they know them they can
tell you i do this this this this and
you're like man you're on your game i
need to do a good job here and i'm
motivated by that not scared by that
yeah it's a perfect little connection
there's a whole chapter on in the book
and what often happens for people is
that emotional thing we're talking about
earlier like that olympian that olympian
that emotion of anxiety
is that's they're using that to raise
their necessity to do better they're
like i'm going to use this feeling i
have and transform it to do better yes
even though everyone else would identify
that same emotions i'm scared they're
going to say this feeling is going to
make me focus this feeling that i want
to have right now i'm going to you know
put my a game on yeah and it's so cool
because all the high performers i
interviewed over 300
literally verified high performers we
use objective measures whether they're
highest performing in their company or
whether they fill out the high
performance indicator and we have this
assessment now that can basically show
these you're probably a high performer
if you score in these areas and these
six different habits and interviewed
over 300 of them and every one of them
at some point in an interview and these
are structured academic interviews so
they're way less fun than this
and so i'm sorry for everyone who i
interviewed but boy
it's just different and and what i found
out was every one of them talked about
that at some point
taking what they were experiencing and
transforming it into something that gave
them performance edge whether it's a an
artist readying themselves to touch the
canvas
like there's there's there's a thing
that says i want to be a great artist i
want to do a great job and that
self-talk
is
leveling up our necessity
lots of people have amazing strengths
but they don't get off the couch
because they don't feel it's necessary
to win
necessary to succeed necessary to serve
and high performers feel like it is
necessary that i show up today i do a
good job i help others sometimes some
answer in a spiritual realm they say i
feel called to do this i feel it is my
mission i feel god has given me these
gifts and i don't want to waste that and
that for them is a very spiritual
emotional connection to it's necessary
for me to kick some butt
do well deliver other people they really
got to mentally
get themselves in that i'm a little in
between i have to
say things to myself
before i walk into a situation
to make me better
like before i came through those doors
like you have a bathroom out there and i
went in the bathroom and i do a little
self-talk to myself and i bounce in
place and i take 10 deep breaths and i'm
talking to myself so that i just i'm
ready reveal uncertainty
this one
is the opposite dynamic of how i used to
think of confidence right we think of
confident people as people are just like
you know it's like wonder woman right is
confident we think of superman is
confident who just knows everything
really what it turns out to be high
performers are a lot listen to this high
performers are a lot less superman and a
lot more clark kent
that's what it turned to be in all the
research with millions of data points in
all of my conversations high performers
were much more likely to reveal
things like
i don't know
things like
i'm i'm unsure
things like how do you think this should
go things like could could you kind of
help me with this
like high performers literally
explicitly share
that they don't know how it's going they
don't know how it's supposed to go that
they need some help that they need some
mentorship that they need some guidance
that's confidence
confidence is not holding back
the deck of cards of your weaknesses
confidence
is a comfort with vulnerability
and when people say vulnerability they
often don't know what they mean when
we're talking about vulnerability
specifically related to confidence and
high performance like measurable
outcomes
the thing that we can measure and see is
that high performers in group meetings
in team meetings in social situations
more often share their insecurity
they more often say
i don't know how this is supposed to go
or you know they'll be the person you
know
at that fruit punch bowl who says you
know i don't really know anybody here um
i don't really know how to start to uh
meet some of these people could you
introduce me to somebody
and that's how they handle the social
networking where they're they're awkward
they instead of just sitting back at the
punch bowl drowning their sorrows and
feeling bad about themselves they engage
the person next to them say hey you know
what i feel kind of awkward here i don't
know a lot of people could you introduce
me
that's how high performers are handling
these little situations in life
they're not the most confident person in
the meeting who goes i know everything
here they're the most confident going
you know what i don't know this here's
my question what do you guys think
and that is how you lead
confidently you reveal that you don't
know everything know your why is nice
know your why and give yourself edge for
it
what do you mean let me give you an
example two guys walking out on the
track field
who's gonna win well equal quality of
experience
similar times maybe they've raced before
the guy at the block so i'm gonna bet on
is the guy who came out and said
i gotta do this for my mom
they have a reason to perform at
heightened levels
and they have connected to that over and
over
now again some of this
brendan but the finding the research is
they just do that more often
than underperformers or even you know
good performers
they're more connected to their reasons
why and they're stirring it man it's
like and they do it from two angles one
angle is your your like your internal
standards
like my values or my self-expectations
say i gotta crush this because that's
who i freaking am yeah like when you
walk out you're like
you're not gonna you know screw around
on when you're playing handball you're
like this is who
i'm loose i'm an athlete yeah i'm gonna
kick some ass here yeah it's that self
expectation okay then though they pair
it
with external obligation
like my team needs me to do this
the deadline says this time there's
there's some kind of external
they don't call it pressure my family
something bigger than themselves
something bigger than themselves yeah
yeah and that's what that was another
thing i was surprised by they don't say
they they rarely use the word pressure
because they want it
like people who use pressure they don't
want it
but high performers
i found they want they like they're
connected i'm doing this for a bigger
cause a bigger reason a team or yeah
there's sometimes just like deadline
like i'm i'm an unbelievably high
performing writer when there's a
deadline i'm worth a weapon right
before that you know i'm i'm not always
on my game so but if you have those
reasons so you gotta have your internal
reasons and your external reasons and
then your job is remind yourself of that
more often passion plus growth plus
contribution equals personal
satisfaction yeah
yeah it's like
those all coming together a lot of
people have never experienced
and it's hard for you and i'd say that's
personal development guys
but it's true there's a lot of people
who've never had those three completely
line up so they're not satisfied even
with
their job or their career or their life
because the passion isn't there
even if the passions are they don't feel
like they're growing but everybody i
talk to do you remember that first
personal development book you read do
you remember that first time you wrote
tons of notes about what you wanted your
life to be about do you remember that
first time you watched the movie
inspired you to go change there was fire
there
because that learning
it opened up your mind to a new level of
existence for you
and as soon as you saw it you were like
oh ambition hits your heart
and now if you can match it with
contribution and you can see
how
that passion or that fire or that
learning or that growth all aligns to
some type of impact
now you're getting me fired up because
now i can see the outcome
of all the work a lot of people don't do
the work because they don't believe the
outcome
that's interesting you know if
psychologists talk about the power of
expectancy um when we talk about
motivation there's only two things that
spark motivation one is ambition
and that is i want more
of or i want a greater depth of right i
want a greater depth of connection with
my lady that's ambition where i want a
better meditative practice that's
ambition all right i want to be better
at my job that's ambition so it starts
with ambition but ambition if it's not
coupled with what they call expectancy
in psychology you're screwed
expectancy says i believe
that i can figure that out i believe
that i can achieve that i believe that
that is possible for me
because if we don't believe it's
possible for me you can show them all
the results from a thousand people
right how many people say i want to get
in great shape
you know i'm
tom i'm a new ketosis i'm doing the
ketosis thing man and they they hop on
your instagram and but then they see
they see the cuts they see the changes
they see the transformations but they
don't believe it's possible for them
so they don't try
expectancy is their problem you gotta
bust through the beliefs to get them to
understand that it is possible for them
not for other people for them
and if you can open that gate for
somebody
and
often that's only achieved through
learning
then you get somebody who starts really
moving ahead forward i mean really
moving ahead like the second they go
wait that's possible for me they'll try
50 stupid things right they'll try
anything
but if they don't lose possible then
they'll just quit if you're in this
place where you're you really feel like
you're struggling
but you're like
i'm working so hard i would say what
she's telling me you know achievement is
not the problem alignment is once we got
her aligned i mean her life came back i
mean literally this person felt like
their life was a waste
like they had spent 20 years doing
something that wasn't the right thing
and there's a lot of guilt and shame and
frustration
there and i'm like europe
but she didn't feel
right because she wasn't an alignment as
soon as we got her alignment i mean
literally weeks she changed i mean you
would have thought she had you know some
renaissance of the mind and it wasn't
that many things just sometimes you're
actually not off
by you know 50 feet like you think you
are you're you're off
by like four or five degrees
and if you can align your relationships
your career and your health back into
the right angle for you you come back to
life
[Music]
if you want even more brendan burchard
check out the video right there next to
me i think you'll love it continue to
believe and i'll see you there double
down on your goodness
you want to have an exceptional and
incredible 2020 you want to find
purposes here double down on your
goodness
adopt the role model mindset and say how
can i be a role model